the u.s mexico border is experiencing a
full-blown crisis
about a hundred thousand people arrived
there last month alone trying to get in
here and so many did
one reason for this crisis is the
behavior of the mexican government
that country's economy relies profoundly
relies on remittances sent back from the
united states
that means instead of caring for its own
poor mexico can just offload them on
us not to mention the poor of central
america
despite this mexico still receives
hundreds of millions of dollars in
direct
foreign aid from the united states in
addition to all the indirect aid nafta
has provided
is there any reason that should continue
juan hernandez is the secretary of
migrants and foreign affairs the mexican
state of
guanajuato and he joins us tonight
thanks very much uh for joining us mr
hernandez so
we think of mexico as an ally
i grew up right on the mexican border
i've always thought of mexico as an as
an ally to the united states and i think
the people are friendly
but the mexican government is clearly
hostile to
american interests i want to read three
quotes from a mexican government
official and
these are direct quotes we are betting
mexican-americans will think
mexico first even unto the seventh
generation
mexican demons through the united states
are quote going to keep one foot in
mexico they are not going to
dissimulate assimilate in the sense of
not being mexican
and final quote we have recognized that
the mexican population is 100 million in
mexico and 23 million
who live in the united states we are a
united nation those quotes are from you
and i wonder if a government takes that
position
that it's sending foreign nationals into
your country
yeah that's right that's a hostile act
so why are we sending money to a country
committing hostile acts against no it's
not my friend no
it's not no no it's not a hostile act at
all what is it
except the united states and mexico are
friends they are
partners no i i mentioned and i think
that's a quote for about 15 years ago
uh has your position to change the same
as you did back then and i hope i
haven't gotten too old either
no we've been talking about this for
about 15 years that is true the the fox
administration
right and and you know and that and
that's
my friend that here we are 15 years
maybe more and the situation
at the border the the migration
immigration system united states
is still broken i remember a dozen years
ago
my friend we were talking about how the
united states canada and mexico should
work together
as three independent nations i'm not
pushing for
opening borders but yes we should work
as a block we have a
good thing going we do we do commerce
let me ask you hold on one billion
dollars every day
every day so but why shouldn't tell me
officials the united states are now
saying
let's close the border some officials
the united states so but why
isn't the mexican government stopping
migrants from central america before
they get to the united states instead
mexico is encouraging them to come here
that's not the behavior of an ally
they're not welcome they're not here
legally we have a process by which
people can come legally they're not
going through that process so that's an
act of hostility you can lie about it
all you want but we don't know that it
is
so why are we paying you money no no no
no no don't don't call me
don't call me a liar let's talk about
these immigrants number one
these are individuals coming yes from
central america
these are good people why don't you stop
listening if they're good people then
why don't you they're right now about
twenty thousand
why don't you let them stay these are
families fifty percent of them
just a minute my friend the mexican
nation
has been giving them visas they can stay
till up to a year
in the country of mexico work in mexico
they are in a
legal way my friends which is
internationally the way to do it they
are
asking but hold on wait wait wait wait a
second wait wait but
i'm confused i'm confused that sounds
first of all
wrong with this no actually it sounds a
little racist to me by the standards
that you have explained so
you have these very good people waiting
no and you let them stay for a year at
work
why not let them do what we do hold on
no why not let them stay forever
and vote in your elections but remain
guatemalans and hondurans
unto the seventh generation as you said
about your own
people about mexican citizens why not
let them do that and stay forever and
they could maybe account for like a
third of your population
after 100 years why would that be bad
why are you kicking them out after a
year
these are these are individuals that are
escaping
hunger that are escaping violence
there's about 250
million people around the world that are
migrating looking
for a better life these individuals have
chosen these good people
these are not bad people why are you
hold on please answer my question
get asylum but why not why don't you use
that once
in mexico you allowed them over your
border
simple question why are you kicking them
out they're good people who just want to
work why are you taking advantage of
that
mexico today if you look at the last i
think it's six years if you look at the
numbers
mexico has now deported more people
to central america i know it's just
united states
numbers have diminished and diminished
so they're good people but you're
looking
forward to the next time we'll discuss
it no no but the the the immigrants
going to the united st
are less and less people going in and
those the united states needs are about
all right
we're out of time 400 right now i still
don't understand why these great people
are being deported by mexico
mexico is a hostile power that is
seeking to undermine every country
today both in the united states and
mexico how we are going to treat
other human beings in the state of
guanajuato we are going to do the right
thing
in the mexican association you're not
doing the right thing actually not
getting back
into the united states that i love so
much we'll also do the right thing i
appreciate it
thank you so much thank you my friend